you guys she's in i'm lauren zima and we
are still in the royalty and the royalty
this week is pure I am pleased to
announce that Meghan Markel has been
officially accepted by the Queen of
England herself we've been talking about
how the royal family has been welcoming
Meghan but now the Queen has signed on
the Royal dotted line so what does that
mean well this is an official letter
from the Queen approving her quote most
dearly beloved grandson's marriage to
megan Markel dearly beloved grandson we
are gathered here today using a lot of
capital letters of the Queen declares
her consent to their contract of
matrimony first of all so sweet how the
Queen refers to Harry most dearly
beloved grandson second we forgot Harry
have this many names Prince Henry
Charles Albert David and then there's
Megan wait Rachel Megan Markel Megan
Marco's actual first name is Rachel all
this time did not know that
oh this letter might be short but it is
simply packed full of little nuggets of
information and actually it's also
missing something so guys we discovered
back when the Queen gave a similar
letter of consent to Will and Kate she
also called will her most dearly beloved
grandson and she dubbed Kate her quote
trusty and well-beloved Catherine there
was no such love for Rachel Megan Markel
so should we be panicking okay okay look
let's break this down the Queen had
known Kate way longer and we know per an
ET source that the royal family has been
quote embracing Megan it's a lot all at
once guys Megan and Harry are moving
pretty fast and like we said in our last
video Megan's been kind of a royal rule
breaker you should go check it out
she has been switching things up way
more than Kate ever did speaking out in
political movements and wearing her hair
in a messy bun so what does this mean
it's gonna be fine guys
it's gonna be fine
for comparison Kate and will met at
school in 2001 they got married in 2011
do the simple math that's ten years
versus Megan and Harry
they met in July 2016 announced their
engagement and moved in together in
November 2017 they're getting married in
May 2018 that's all within about two
years so let's just give the Queen a
minute okay all I really needed was a
plan by the way the Queen has to write
these notes due to the royal marriages
act of wait for it 1772
that's the kind of lengthy histories the
royal family is accustomed to and we
know these ladies are building a bond
just a few days earlier Megan and the
Queen stepped out together for Megan's
first royal public event alongside the
Queen it was the Commonwealth service at
Westminster Abbey that's the largest
interfaith gathering in the UK that
happens every year Megan looked gorgeous
and Bridal in this Amanda Wakeley coat
and Stephen Jones beret you can get the
coat yourself for a casual $1,199 and
here's something less expensive and more
meaningful to make you tear up Stephen
Jones was a favorite hat maker of none
other than Princess Diana's and just a
day before this event was the UK's
Mother's Day and Harry and Megan
reportedly spent it having lunch with
the Queen Megan is in the Family Guy's
it's fine
Megan and Kate even appeared to be
wearing the same heels at that event so
dearly beloved trustee loved beautiful
royal human grandchildren we are all
good to go as we keep moving forward
towards the royal wedding day let us
know what you think of how quickly
things are moving along with Megan you
can leave comments on YouTube and
Facebook and tweet me anytime I'll just
be sipping my tea see you guys next week
you